Okay.
Welcome everybody.
Welcome to toxic Google.
We're coming to you live from the Google plex in Tunis and everybody out there
in live stream land.
We're going to be talking about Claude Shannon today.
Someone that made,
many of you may know in many of you may not know about machines,
machines to play chess machines.
The juggle all machines that the our flame throwing trumpets and yeah,
how about the curation of information theory?
It's all about Claude Shannon and he's one of the most important pioneers of
computer science and our digital age that most of us barely know about,
but no longer because Jimmy Sony and Rob Goodman have written this book,
the full full,
the first full biography of Claude Shannon and they're here today to talk to us
about it.
So come on in.
Welcome Jimmy and rob
[inaudible].
Okay.
So let's start briefly,
can you describe why Claude Shannon is so important?
Why we should care about them and what were his major contributions?
Oh yeah,
I take it away.
Wow.
Um,
so I think Claude Shannon was important for a couple of reasons and obviously we
don't need to tell this crowd,
uh,
why he made such a big difference.
But we sort of wrote the book,
uh,
in a sense to do is think about the gratitude that we have a does someone like
Claude Shannon who was responsible for so much of the technology.
We're a lot,
we rely on every day,
uh,
scientifically we think that is too big accomplishments where his,
1937 masters thesis where he,
uh,
does an important job of laying the foundations of digital computing of Zeros
and ones.
And a,
a big part of that accomplishment was showing the connection between,
um,
a boolean logic and the relays or switches that were a part of computing
systems.
And Shannon got his start working on a giant analog computing systems,
but he really did a lot to,
uh,
uncover the potential of a digital systems.
Uh,
Chris Dixon road and rate piece about this and the Atlantic.
And we read a couple of days ago.
Um,
and the way he put it,
I thought was really evocative and I wish we could stolen this for our book.
Uh,
he says that,
that Shane had thought about how to map logic on fiscal world and that,
I think that's a really succinct way of putting it.
Um,
the other big contribution by the way,
he was just 21,
so it makes me feel like crap.
I'm already 33.
I'm not gonna live up to that,
but anyway,
at 32,
which is still younger than me,
um,
uh,
Shannon,
releases what a lot of people consider it as masterpiece,
which again,
in this crowd probably knows very well about it says mathematical theory of
communication,
uh,
in 1948,
um,
which does a number of things like exploring the properties that communication
systems have in common,
uh,
coming up with the concept of the bit to objectively quantify information.
And then of course,
coming up with those,
uh,
digital codes to,
to compress information and also to accurately transmit information in a noisy
channel.
Um,
and,
uh,
the reaction to this was just a remarkable John Pierce who we were talking a
little bit about before we went on and say it,
it came as a bomb and that we called the chapter on Shannon's,
uh,
communications.
Uh,
he is,
uh,
information theory paper,
the bomb,
because that,
that's the kind of impact of course it had in the science engineering community.
And,
uh,
we were sort of setting out to explore why this matters for our lives now and
why people even without a science or math or engineering background ought to
know what information theory is and what information theory makes possible.
Um,
and do a little justice to Shannon who deserves a little more name recognition.
Thanks.
Now neither of you are computer scientists or mathematicians.
Oh,
you got us our sugar and yeah.
So can you tell us a little bit about your backgrounds and how did you learn
about Shannon?
You come to write about him?
So I had been gifted a book called the idea factory by a friend.
Uh,
and the book is by a guy named John Gardner was,
became it,
became a close advisor to us is we were doing this project and the idea factory,
is it a narrative history of bell labs.
Um,
w the way we joke about it,
and this is not meant as an offense to anybody in the room,
but the,
we call it,
we said if,
if you could envision a freak merger of Google,
apple and Facebook,
uh,
that was bell labs in the 20th century.
Um,
it was the second largest employer in the country after the federal government.
Uh,
it,
it was,
it had a,
basically a government back of monopoly,
uh,
ownership over the telephone system.
So had an enormous resources,
um,
and in a way,
you know,
it,
it embraced a lot of what the people in this room embrace,
uh,
in the sense that,
you know,
it gave people a remarkable freedom and flexibility to do different kinds of
work.
Um,
Shannon was actually a part of something called the mathematical research group.
We're,
we're basically,
it was a group for all the misfits within bell labs.
They didn't know where else to put them,
so they would assign them to a man named Thornton fry.
And he built what was essentially an in house consulting organization,
but it was a consulting organization where they got to pick the projects they
worked on and didn't have to work on anything they didn't want to work on.
Uh,
and so he was a part of this incredible group of PhDs.
And what it gave bell labs was this,
this just unbelievable source of talent.
And it gave them six Nobel prizes credit for,
you know,
co-invented the laser inventing the fax machine,
sending the first long distance phone call,
sending the first longest since television transmission.
Uh Oh,
the transistor came out of bell labs.
So this book is an extraordinary look at that place and the people within it and
one of the people whose profile throughout the book as Claude Shannon,
and you get him in bits and pieces because it's not his biography,
it's a story of the company.
And so you get his story weaved in with others.
And I sort of went looking,
uh,
for a biography of Shannon and I did,
I didn't really find one that,
that covered his life end to end.
And I said to myself,
this just seems like something that the,
it just seems crazy to me that this guy's fingerprints are all over the modern
world,
that,
that people in this room 50,
60 years later work on things that he worked on or pioneered and that we don't
have the faintest [inaudible] much of the public doesn't have any sense of who
he is.
Not only that,
even the people like you who might know who he is,
don't necessarily know the details of his personal life or of his early life or
his education.
Uh,
rob and I are old friends from Duke and we've done a lot of writing together and
a lot of writing separately.
And our first book was a book.
What's a look at the ancient Roman Senator Cato.
And we were both kind of kicking around for another project and when I came,
when it came to this,
I just sort of send it to rob.
I,
it's like,
we could do something here.
Like you and I are not engineers.
We're not computer scientists are not mathematicians.
But that's exactly the reason that we ought to do this because if we can make
this accessible to people,
uh,
we're going to have,
in order to do that,
we're going to have to learn all this stuff from scratch and try to make people
understand why he was important.
And we pitched the project to,
um,
Simon and Schuster to an editor and writer named Alice Mayhew,
whose name you don't know,
but you know the name of the people she works with.
Walter Isaacson,
a Sylvia Nasir,
who's the author of a beautiful mind.
And so she understood right away what this book was,
which is,
it's in part the story of a life,
uh,
Claude Shannon's life from beginning to end.
And it's in part a story of discovery.
What does it take for a mind to produce the kinds of things that Claude Shannon
produced.
Um,
she understood that because that is what a beautiful mind was.
Uh,
that is what Walter Isaacson's book on an Einstein was.
A,
there's a really wonderful book called Tuxedo Park,
uh,
which a few people in this room have probably looked at.
But,
uh,
another look at someone,
Alfred Lee Loomis,
who is this character who funded a lot of wartime physics,
but she got,
she,
she just knew the model for the book.
We approached her because I'm interested in like the idea and we were off to the
races.
It was quite a leap from Keto to computers.
Well it was nice working with,
with a figure who is relatively more recent history.
We could talk to his friends and his loved ones.
A Cato was a bit more impenetrable in that way.
Yeah.
You are both trained as journalists.
Just just briefly,
what are your current positions now?
Sure.
So,
uh,
I'm an author,
I'm also an editor at the New York observer
and I'm a PHD candidate in Colombia.
My in my day job is in political theory.
Great.
Okay.
So let's talk a little bit about Shannon's life.
Uh,
what about his early years where he grew up,
his parents,
his teachers,
other influences before he left home?
Yeah.
So Shannon grows up in this,
a tiny town called the Gaylord Michigan,
uh,
2000 or 3000 people.
And one of my personal favorite that research gets we did for this book was
looking at the Gaylord,
a newspaper archives from the 19,
uh,
tens and twenties that are online,
but they actually digitize their whole newspapers.
So you can read the whole thing.
And it's the kind of town where the headlines are.
Things like Vern mass loses finger,
um,
meeting called to discuss artichokes and a girl kills wolf with broomstick.
So I tried to be pretty awesome and she needs a book.
Um,
but that was the kind of town that it was.
so the cool thing about it was that,
uh,
you know,
Shannon didn't have any kind of a tortured,
tormented childhood like some a geniuses did,
but he had a channel to hood where he could,
uh,
play with things and make things and build things.
And you sort of this tradition then did Gertner also talks about in bell labs
with these kind of,
uh,
great Midwestern inventor tinkerer,
scientist engineers who come out of the early 20th century in often many small
towns in the Midwest.
Um,
and one thing that we were able to,
to talk about the book and the research and a little more detail worthy projects
that Shannon tinkered on as a boy.
Um,
one of the coolest was he made a barbed wire telephone network that ran between
his house and his best friend's house.
Um,
and this was not a unique to Shannon.
there were lots of,
uh,
sort of off the grid places that didn't have major telephone coverage and
farmers would speak to one another,
um,
by a rigging up electrics and signals to run a over the fences that were already
there.
So,
uh,
Shannon didn't invent this,
but he was,
you know,
10 or 12.
So it was pretty impressive for a kid of that age to a rig it up.
Um,
he rigged up with his friend or Rodney,
a a barn elevator that,
uh,
went from floor one floor two in the barn and it said that Shannon was the
mastermind.
Rodney was the Guinea pig.
Um,
and Rodney survives.
So Rod,
he's here.
He lived,
we talked to is,
well,
we,
we saw an interview with his sister.
So,
um,
uh,
also he had a,
he had a pretty academically inclined family.
His Dad was a know one of those kind of Jack of all trades that you'd see in a
small town like this.
So he was the a furniture salesman,
the town undertaker and the judge of probate.
Um,
he was much older than Shannon,
so they didn't really have a very,
uh,
strong connection because they're just the big age difference.
His mother was a teacher and occasionally the high school principal and a sister
Catherine clot always said was better than him at math.
And he was part of the reason,
she was part of the reason I think she was three or four years old and that he
got into the field in the first place as sort of a sibling rivalry thing.
And she would always,
uh,
give him math puzzles as a boy.
My,
my other favorite thing about China's childhood,
he mentioned that his favorite story growing up was a Edgar Allen Poe's,
the Goldbug bug,
which I don't know if anyone's read it,
but I looked into it and it's,
it's the only at ground post story that ends with this lecture on,
uh,
cryptanalysis,
um,
that,
uh,
about this a giant block of text and say a he buried treasure code from pirate
and this guy goes into a,
the is a friend goes into this internal detail about how you decipher it using
redundancies and the texts that Decoda what symbols mean and so on.
It goes on for 10 pages and Shannon just hate this ups and it's pretty fitting
that he goes on to actually become someone working in cryptography as part of
World War Two.
Well,
we'll probably get into that,
but that,
that's the background it comes out of.
Um,
uh,
pretty happy,
mathematically inclined,
a tinkering and climbs sort of kid that finds a way to put that to good use.
Anything special about his schooling at that,
at that time?
Did you get anything?
I'm not teachers.
Principals,
not particularly.
He actually,
you know,
and this will be comfort for anybody who struggles with this,
but you got some B's on his report card.
Um,
they released,
we learned this by pouring over the Gaylord Herald Times,
which at the time would or would publish,
uh,
who is sort of the top of the class and that sort of thing.
Um,
so he got some bees.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
he remembers later on he writes a letter to a teacher who he remembers very
fondly and talks about,
you know,
the students he remembered from his class.
Um,
there was nothing within the records that we could find that suggested that
there was anything that happened at school that was a particular kind of
important.
Soon I think I were to take a step back in a way.
The fact that he didn't have the kind of intense upbringing that like a
Beethoven did,
right,
or,
um,
or a John Stuart mill or where their parents are like drilling them in Latin and
Greek and trying to turn them into prodigies.
Um,
Claude Shannon's parents seem to be,
seem to embrace what I think we call now,
like free range parenting.
Like Claude Shannon was playing with things he'd probably should have been
playing with.
Um,
but he,
it gave him this,
uh,
ability to work with his hands to be very practical.
Um,
I'm assuming that a lot of the people in this room,
uh,
played with early desktop computers and built and rebuild things.
And,
and I did too.
And so I kind of identified with this part of Shannon's life,
cause I remember staying up super late at night,
like trying to reconstruct computers and built computers and swap out parts and
waiting for the latest video card and all the rest.
And I was writing all of this on a laptop that if I took it apart,
I would've violated like the terms and conditions of the laptop.
Right.
And I just had this moment of thinking like,
wow,
you know,
I wonder if,
uh,
we both had kids during the time of writing this book.
Uh,
I wonder if my daughter is going to ever have the ability to like take things
apart the way the Claude Shannon did,
or even in the kind of novice way that I did.
But this was somebody who played with broken radios and we'd go around
collecting parts and assembling things.
The education he had was,
I think a more informal education.
He was very smart.
People recognized it right away.
Uh,
high school only took three years for him.
Um,
and he,
he gets A's in the subjects that mattered to him and bees in the subjects that
don't.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but otherwise it was a fairly ordinary childhood.
You have to feel it for reading the bill abs book that this entire generation of
brilliant early electrical engineers that came out of the Midwest with,
they didn't have computers to take her with you.
You get the feeling they could like take a tractor apart and put it together
with their eyes closed.
And not only if they put it bed,
he would have wanted to like get that.
That was like their first instinct when,
when Claude Shannon is in a nursing home at the end of his life in a very sad
period where he is fighting and struggling with Alzheimer's,
he takes apart his walker to try to figure out if he could reconstruct it to
make it work better.
Um,
so this is something that has just threaded into him and who he is.
And it's like one of the pieces of the story that,
that is endearing and I assume is endearing to a lot of people in this room who
probably have similar inclinations apropos of your daughter being able to take
her computer apart in 1984 Stanford,
the Macintosh has come out and it hurts.
Felt comes to give a talk about it and he goes,
look at this box.
Isn't it beautiful?
You can't take it apart.
You need a special tool.
You can't get inside.
People are going boom.
Right?
Cause it's like a toaster.
Who'd want to take your toaster apart?
Voice from the back of the room?
Me.
Uh,
so these are the times we live in.
So out of high school,
he goes to University of Michigan.
Uh,
I actually worked for someone from University of Michigan here at Google who
says,
Yay,
let's talk about Shannon in Michigan and then on to MIT.
So what happened in his college in it later academic year?
So one of our favorite other pieces of information from this period as we dug up
his college applications.
So basically that the papers you can get on dead people,
but,
uh,
we found his college application and in those days you could cross out your
spelling errors
in pencil and still centered in,
it was like three pages and fill in the blank.
Uh,
so it was not the most,
he was a great public university.
Uh,
and if you were in Michigan high school student and graduate and you could go to
a Michigan,
a university.
So Shannon double majors in engineering and math,
uh,
and again,
um,
other people did it,
but he was sort of unique and both having those sort of a abstract background in
mathematical logic,
uh,
and uh,
and especially a bull's theory.
And in a,
in the more practical engineering side of electrical engineering,
which we can get into.
But anyway,
he sees a job application one day from a viva Bush at a MIT to apply to MIT as a
graduate student,
a and with special emphasis on working on,
uh,
bushes,
differential analyzer,
which is just a fascinating machine that we learned about,
um,
in the process of working on this book,
which is of course one of the great early on room size,
analog computers.
Um,
and one of the things that I learned that the processes that,
you know,
when,
when you say analog,
you know,
we don't think of the derivation of that word,
but it's very literally at a machine that makes analogies.
Uh,
Bush has a great quote where he says that,
um,
if for instance we want to study the effects of the differential equations,
uh,
that operate on a bridge swaying in the wind to see if the bridge will stay up.
Um,
we design this a analog computer so that it will in a sense obey the same
equations that are affecting the bridge.
We set it up to make an analogy for the bridge undergoes.
And then this applies for engineering problems and bushes using it for questions
like,
um,
the stability of the phone network and the electrical grid,
but also for a more advanced physics problems.
Uh,
later on it was applied to things like I'm studying cosmic radiation or studying
atomic structure.
Uh,
so it's,
it's the best,
most advanced calculating devices today.
So Shannon comes to work on this.
Um,
and uh,
Bush really has an eye for talent.
He is a great one of these great scientific networkers and organizers.
Uh,
and then you put Shannon to work specifically on working on the,
uh,
the relays that are attached to a later version of the differential analyzer
that sort of helps reconfigured the system on the fly in a sense.
So you don't have to break it down and rebuild it for each new problem.
And then Shannon gets to thinking about the connections in analogies between the
relays are the kind we saw in the Theseus video.
And I'm a boolean logic.
The idea that,
uh,
um,
the Janet comes up was essentially that,
uh,
you can use switches as the,
the,
uh,
units and symbols and operators in acting out a boolean logic that a ones and
Zeros can represent yeses and nos.
That a series and sequence can represent ands and ors,
uh,
that,
um,
whether or not that outcome happens like a light turns on and represent a,
the F's a of a boolean logic and the outcome.
Um,
so Shannon writes is a great master's thesis,
um,
that explains how to use these principles of boolean logic to change,
uh,
circuit design.
Um,
so that rather than being a trial and error process that you can sort of have a
knack for,
Shannon actually shows how you can dramatically simplify and do everything
that's required to construct these circuits on paper.
And he actually does a couple of examples.
He says,
here's the circuit for a basic adding machine.
Here's the circuit for a combination lock.
And even he draws them in for the first time.
Someone is a simplifying the process and designing these,
uh,
basic computers or it gets,
with any kind of yes or no gate,
uh,
entirely on paper.
And of course this is a sort of blockbuster for its time.
It winds and all sorts of awards.
It winds him the Nobel prize,
which is like the Nobel prize with the letters transposed,
which is a award for the best young engineer,
a young engineering paper.
Um,
but it's recognized as,
as people would go on and say it was probably the most influential master's
thesis maybe ever.
Um,
we both wrote master's theses.
We're not quite in that way.
Um,
but,
uh,
Shannon's certainly wasn't in a league of its own.
And then that's what sort of,
um,
largest him to a degree of prominence and puts him in these upper echelons of
the science and engineering world.
And the different judge in is kind of one of the first ratifications of Charles
Babbage's,
right?
The differentiators of the different engine or William Gibson's,
if you'd like to book a novel,
uh,
was terrain building his indignation machine at the same time.
And it was that machine at all related.
Is that an analog machine?
So it was a,
Turing and Shannon are working on a lot of the same concepts at the same time.
Uh,
and so I think the touring machine paper was published while I was in a turning
machine paper who was a that the same year he's working on enigma until the war
about like five or six years later on.
But one of the more interesting elements of the story is that they,
so they're separated by an ocean,
but thinking and working on many of the same things and they're also very
similar in sort of personality and temperament.
Um,
neither of them,
you know,
they're,
they're not the life of the party.
Uh,
they are pretty quiet.
They keep to themselves and they,
uh,
and this is a bit of probably a leap forward in the chronology,
but it's worth doing.
But there's a period where the British government is suspicious about whether or
not the Americans are going to have the technological wherewithal to send
messages that are actually encrypted and actually protected.
There's a lot of suspicion on both sides,
but particularly the British.
So the Brits Send Alan Turing to the United States to do a tour of different
facilities in New York and in Washington DC.
And the idea is he needs to essentially stress test these devices that are used
to for,
you know,
for example,
for Franklin Roosevelt to communicate with Winston Churchill.
And so touring is sent to the United States.
Um,
funny enough,
there's enough suspicion that his paperwork is actually not cleared and he gets
held up and immigrations and customs for a little while.
Um,
he ends up at bell labs where he spends a good chunk of time and in what,
in what is one of the most incredible moments,
I think in computing history,
Alan Turing and Claude Shannon have tea basically every day while they're at
bell laboratories.
Uh,
and these are not guys who are going to go chat up,
you know,
the sort of,
they're,
they're not,
you know,
they're not unfriendly people,
but they're certainly not going to go make new friends very easily.
Um,
so they empty every day.
And interestingly enough,
the secrecy of the work that they're,
that they're doing prevents either of them from talking about code breaking or
cryptography.
And so it frees them up to talk about artificial intelligence.
They are,
they are sitting around asking questions like,
could you build a computer that could work as well as a brain.
Uh,
and this is in the 1940s.
Um,
and so you have these two giants sitting together at t and like,
we always like,
like to wonder like what it must have been like,
uh,
in that particular moment.
And so the,
uh,
the,
the sort of,
there's a couple of other pieces of story.
One is that touring actually visits Shannon at his home in New York's West
village and we think maybe a half dozen if that people visited his home.
Uh,
and so it says something that Turing was there.
Um,
but they ended up striking up a friendship and,
uh,
so that,
that center,
the one connection between them intellectually,
they do stay in touch.
Uh,
and later on after the war is over,
Shannon and his wife go and visit touring and like,
like kind of a old ballplayer as I guess they go down to Turing's basement and
start playing with the computer that he's built and they start keep,
they just keep up with is to pick up exactly where they left off.
Um,
and the story obviously has a tragic ending,
uh,
turning,
you know,
by by someone guns,
it's suicide and by all accounts it seems to be suicide that there are still
some discrepancies about that.
Um,
that happened shortly after Shannon's visit,
but we always sort of think that there's something,
um,
appropriate in the fact that they were a,
that these two war time code breakers and code makers were able to reunite after
the war.
And you know,
without missing a beat,
they go and play with this,
uh,
this device and Turing's basement that actually is trying,
he's trying to make a computer that'll talk.
Uh,
and that's what,
that's what he's,
he's working on.
Interesting because Shannon goes onto a bell labs,
which is the pinnacle of research and making people talk.
We have ways to make the talk.
Anyways.
So let's talk about bell labs.
Uh,
not just in the context of Shannon and tournament,
but bill labs in general.
And when we talk about bell labs is,
you know,
the idea factory traces its hundred year history,
more or less.
Um,
it started in New York downtown and then by the time the war came and they'd,
they'd moved to New Jersey and Shannon was there through that entire transition.
So there's a lot to say about right then you would bill,
right for those of you that,
or the Google New York offices,
Bell Labs,
you can still see the building,
uh,
near the,
near the highlight now.
And you can walk across the high line,
look to,
uh,
what was the original bell labs building and even had to one of the ports for a
train to come in and out before when there's an industrial area.
But,
uh,
anyway,
um,
and we've written a little bit about bell labs and separate pieces about the
book.
And we've said the bill adds probably isn't a good example of how to make a
successful company because,
well,
the answer,
how many external advantages they had.
A,
they,
they had,
they had the patents going back to bill,
they had the government monopolies.
So they never really had to worry about money.
But at the same time,
um,
we also say that a,
he,
if successful companies in the economy can behave like bell labs,
we're all better off the build labs,
took that money and put it towards the Edge,
port it into basic research and poured it into the work of people like a Shannon
a little bit earlier before him,
a Clinton Davison who got a Nobel prize for working on the atomic structure.
Um,
but,
but poured into people who didn't do work that immediately paid off in a small
window,
but was enormously important for the development of technology more broadly.
And there's a great quote,
I think it was from the Henry Pollock,
um,
who overlap with Shannon at bell labs who said,
you know,
there's this attitude there that,
um,
we,
uh,
we may not be doing work that's gonna pay off in 10 or 20 years,
but you know,
hey,
we're the phone company,
we're going to be there anyway.
So,
uh,
there's this confidence of,
of being able to have people like Shannon who could,
uh,
you know,
noodle around on whatever.
So that,
that's not Shannon's entire career there.
You know,
when,
when it comes on board at bell labs,
it's wartime and he'd has a lot of assignments so he's not especially happy
about.
And those include a fire control,
which is sort of using statistical modeling to control,
um,
anti aircraft guns of the kind.
We also saw in the video,
um,
take some of those insights,
especially working with the Norbert Wiener who had written a kind of famously
intimidating text on a statistical modeling,
um,
uh,
and some of those insights going to information theory.
And,
and also as Jenny mentioned,
Shannon's working on a,
um,
cryptography on scrambled speech systems.
And then writes a paper that doesn't come out until after the war's over.
But it's about the theoretical conditions for unbreakable code about,
uh,
proving the and breakability of a one time pad code.
Um,
even though,
uh,
it practically it's the kind of code wouldn't be able to implement in actual
wartime conditions.
But,
um,
Shannon takes these insights from fire control from cryptography and from his
other interests.
Andy sort of pours them into this project on information theory.
There's working on a lot of them in his spare time,
um,
and later on during his day job at bell labs and it gets a little more freedom
after the war winds down.
And we have these,
uh,
quotes from his girlfriend at the time who lived in Shannon's building,
um,
said that,
uh,
you know,
some days just didn't want to go to work because it was,
he was stressed out by the,
the crowding in the office by the wartime conditions by the,
the amount of time he had to be in the office.
Uh,
but he was always at home wherever he was.
He was scribbling on Napkins.
He was,
uh,
talking over ideas to himself.
Uh,
he would stare off into space and as you're working on something that was big,
uh,
and after he had a little more freedom to do this,
a full time at bell labs,
this is when he develops his great work and information theory.
And the neat thing is that Shannon is of course not the only one,
especially in the math group of more broadly at bell labs who's doing the sort
of a long term,
uh,
very long horizon sort of basic research.
And of course,
um,
information theory is Shannon's paper is immediately have a theoretical interest
and immediately provokes a so much interest in scientific literature,
doesn't really start to have practical payoffs for many,
many decades down the road.
Um,
but that's the neat thing about what bell labs enable Shannon to do.
They're willing to keep him on a and pay a salary as he worked on this thing
that had enormous payoff,
uh,
you know,
decades down the line and kind of as a final nice gesture when Shannon decides
to take a job at MIT and leave bell labs,
Bell labs decides to keep them on the payroll and they keep an office for him.
Just sort of as a gesture of respect that he was one of the giants.
Um,
we,
we went there to,
into their new building at Murray Hill,
New Jersey.
Um,
they have a bust of Claude Shannon and one of the buildings has been named after
him.
Uh,
but,
but he's still one of the people that is one of the few people along with the
emitters and the transistor that is just a still revered in that place.
It just to,
as a,
to add to that a bit,
I noticed that there were some chess chess boards outside and it called to mind
for me just cause we've been steeped in this,
uh,
bell labs was a vibrant place in that way too.
That there were chess games that there were competitions,
um,
Channon builds at one point,
uh,
I think it's a rock,
paper,
scissors robot and they have a contest against some other guy who built the
rock,
paper,
scissors,
robot.
That might not be the exact story,
but it's something like that.
It was a company that gave people remarkable flexibility.
And I'm not sure that there is,
this is,
this is a hazard of guests.
I'm not sure there is a mathematical theory of communication without bell
laboratories.
Um,
both because of the content of what Claude Shannon was working on.
You know,
there were some times sometimes when he was working on very practical things,
one of his first pieces of work at bell labs is actually looking at,
uh,
the coloration of wires,
within the phone system and whether the coloration of wires of could,
could be improved upon.
And he actually does,
he writes a paper that improves upon the coloration wire.
So some of it got to that.
It's a very practical level.
Um,
but remember he publishes his mathematical theory of communication in the Bell
Systems Technical Journal,
which is an academic journal run by bell labs for the better part of the 20th
century.
It's like corporate blog,
eat your heart out,
right?
I mean this is like not,
this is serious stuff.
This is a lengthy 77 page paper and bell kept this publication going for most of
the 20th century.
And you can read the archives online.
Um,
there is something about a company,
again,
they had a certain blessing in the resources that they had,
but the ways that they chose to use those resources,
we think there's still a lot left to learn from them.
Um,
and again,
the idea factory is a,
is a wonderful way to start.
Um,
but uh,
there are obvious echoes of,
of Bell Labs around here.
Uh,
and,
and I do think that there's something about the kind of freedom they gave people
that led to some remarkable things.
This is a private sector company that won six Nobel Prizes,
uh,
over the course of the 20th.
Not even Shannon.
Yeah,
not even sure.
The one,
one,
two and Shannon and information theory.
Um,
and so you,
you really have to sort of step back and say to yourself,
uh,
you know,
what,
what was in the water.
Uh,
and we do get into some of some of that in the book and they built telephone
poles.
It's still last for 50 years.
Exactly what the design aesthetic,
even better,
the math group that,
um,
that Shannon joins,
one of the rites of passage is they climb like telephone poles and you have to
actually go and be a telephone engineer,
uh,
on the ground for a little while.
And it sort of,
this,
I wouldn't quite call it a ritual because I'm not sure that everybody was
required to do it,
but it was a sort of thing that the math group would just dive in and do that in
order to understand problems.
And they would attach these mathematicians to physicists into engineers and to
others and say,
just go,
go help them for a little while to figure something out.
Uh,
and it was,
it was a pretty amazing thing.
And we should mention that the pull quote,
there's the paper and the Bill Technical Journal and a couple of years later it
was dubbed in scientific American,
the Magna Carta
of information theory.
I mean,
yeah,
when,
when people ask us to explain why this paper matters,
that that's the pull quote.
We use that because it's just the founding document.
This is the thing.
And not only was it the founding document,
but he first,
he basically produced all of the follow on fear hymns improves as well.
He left almost nothing to be done.
It's really obnoxious.
I mean the uh,
the engine,
the other you think about that is when he first publishes it,
and this sort of speaks to the other nice quality of Shannon,
is that he's very modest guy.
He calls it a mathematical theory of communication,
a math and have when it's republished a year later as a book by people who take
it in.
And some of that book is him,
but a lot of it is not,
it's the work of other people.
They put the title,
the mathematical theory of communication,
which just goes to show how highly it was regarded by people in the field within
no time at all.
While we're on the theory it was going to get to it a little later.
Perfect.
But it's so important.
Is there an elegant statement of it?
It's as concise as equals MC squared or Newtons,
Newton's posture,
let's,
or is it really,
really hard to understand?
I think if there's one thing to pull out,
and this is actually,
this is not our choice to pull it out,
but it's Shannon's a formula for a,
um,
bits in terms of h a v a as a measure of probabilities.
Um,
and uh,
the interesting thing,
Shannon's a formula for a bit content is,
um,
on his,
a bust at bell labs and in several other places would have his bust as also on
the back of the tombstone.
And,
uh,
Jimmy went there.
I wasn't able to make that trip where we visited Shannon scourge him.
He visited chance grave in the Mount Auburn Cemetery.
And if you walk around to the back and push aside a couple of bushes,
you can see in grade from the back.
And we spoke to his family.
I think there was some talk of a putting it on the front,
but I think I was his wife.
I think his wife,
so his kids wanted the equation on the front.
Um,
and his wife thought it more appropriate to have it on the back and now it's
covered by a bush.
And so if you go there,
it's a famous cemetery,
Supreme Court justices,
uh,
the presidents of Harvard,
et Cetera,
or they're all buried there.
And um,
if you,
if you have to sort of push the Bush side to see the,
the uh,
the equation and engraved on the back.
And,
and I wouldn't say that,
I think one of the reasons it does kind of sum up the why it's maybe EMC equals
mc squared level maybe,
is that it does sort of encode a lot of information you can unpack.
And one of the things that we like doing in the book as sort of training and
intellectual history of information,
of trying to pin it down and say a physical objective quantity.
And we sort of Christ the different,
uh,
you know,
fumbling attempts to get to it.
Uh,
especially,
uh,
beginning with a,
you know,
Lord Kelvin back in the 19th century,
working on a transatlantic calligraphy,
but also getting into the predecessors that Shannon himself sites,
uh,
Harry Nyquist and Ralph,
hardly both his predecessors at bell labs who also have their own sort of
formulations of a information content.
Um,
and Shannon's addition to this is Ada.
Well the idea that,
um,
uh,
information contest with the size of the symbol vocabulary and sort of already
been there in Nyquist work,
uh,
on,
on telegraphs and then Hartley's work more generally.
But what Shannon comes in,
ebbs and your Norbert Wiener was also working on a similar direction when it
comes in,
adds as a sort of probabilistic element that it's not just a,
um,
the,
the size of the simple vocabulary you're choosing from.
It's the fact that you have to measure in the probability of getting a certain
choice.
And the way the analogy he uses,
um,
for a basic understanding of what a bid is,
is think of a,
a coin,
a fair coin is stored in one bit because there's a 50,
50 chance that can land on heads or tails.
And as you wait the coin more and more in one direction or the other,
uh,
the information content that stores could be said to decrease because the choice
becomes a little more predictable.
But it was Shannon who had it,
that sort of probabilistic twist.
And of course in his modest as he was,
he said,
I didn't think that was a big deal.
I guess we think it's a big deal.
It is a very big deal.
Searching around on the web for some pithy Shannon quotes.
I came up with a couple,
not quit,
maybe not quite as elegant as a,
this is tombstone,
but maybe more,
uh,
more understandable to a lay audience.
And I came up with these,
or Shannon quotes,
information is the negative reciprocal value of probability or information is
the resolution of uncertainty.
And thinking about that,
it struck me.
Um,
if you look at the two poles of his who his most famous work,
you've got Boolean Algebra,
you've got basically,
forgive me Bayesians statistics on the other side,
you've got the certainty and the structure of a binary number system contrasted
with uncertainty,
probability.
Uh,
it's,
it's kind of a nice dipole I think to reflect is his work.
Yeah,
that's a great way of putting it.
We didn't think about anything about that,
that's known for that.
That's really,
I'm going to use that as a poet for the paperback.
That's a really good way forward on that particular audience.
It's uh,
yeah.
I do want to get,
we will get probably deeper into the philosophy and information versus
knowledge.
Actually have a great Frank Zappa.
Can I just say one of the things that we didn't really get into,
because this is something that speaks to people more generally,
who maybe aren't deep into theory,
but want to think about how a theory like that or how something that
consequential it can be developed.
It's incredibly important to remember two things.
One that he started thinking about this in 1938 roughly right in 1937,
1938.
It takes 10 years for this to crystallize into this paper.
You know,
that now has an entire field devoted to a field of study and people read it
every year.
Um,
it takes 10 years.
It takes a long time for this to crystallize.
During that time he's working on cryptography is working on how to shoot things
down from the sky.
Uh,
he's playing with tub,
the telephone system at,
at the,
at enormous scale.
The other thing to remember is he's not working on it full time.
It's,
it's what we affectionately in a recent piece called the side hustle.
Uh,
like,
like I hope I have a side hustle as good as,
as a mathematical theory of communication.
But I think those two things are important because it's really easy to look at
somebody like Shannon and say,
well that's just,
you know,
just full time working on this 10 years.
And it's a,
it's a given.
It really wasn't.
He was,
um,
he was not,
I wouldn't say distracted,
but he was occupied with many other during the time.
And in a way I think that actually makes what he did all the more impressive.
Uh,
but those two facts,
I think people forget it.
And,
and you,
you can read it,
you can see his name next to this paper and in sort of gloss over the fact that
this is a tea is a decade long journey to get to some of the defining principles
in this field from the sublime to the ridiculous.
Let's talk a little bit about Shannon,
the trickster and the,
the,
the tinkerer in the,
maybe even the bone Vivanta all that you say.
He wasn't that much of a social guy,
but,
uh,
I read some stories.
Tell us about them.
And so,
uh,
this is the great thing is that Shannon was born tanker from the,
from the very earliest records will happen.
This is what he did.
But at the same time,
once he sort of becomes the information theory guy,
he has a little more freedom to,
to short of show this off.
And,
and we do think it's nice that Shannon could have kind of made a play towards
becoming a much more public figure,
sort of public intellectual,
a sort of a pontificator on science.
He just,
he's not interested in that.
He's interested in just sort of playing and making things with his hands.
So he has this,
uh,
when he moves into his a house in Massachusetts,
he has a two story workshop addition added to the House that some people call it
the toy room.
I don't think Shannon called softcon today is currently the dad's workshop.
Um,
but he built things in there like the,
the flame throwing trumpet that we mentioned.
Uh,
he had a fleet of customers you're going to say.
So you had off balance going to cycles and made you in a cycling and juggling
simultaneous leave.
And harder,
because apparently juggling and Unicycle,
it was too easy for him.
So he gets really into the scientific study of juggling.
He writes one of the first papers that we know on a jumping physics where he
comes up with an equation,
uh,
you know,
correlating a number of balls,
um,
timing air,
uh,
so on,
um,
he uh,
asks one of his colleagues if he can measure his juggling as you hold some
upside down on the theory that um,
one would be able to kind of combine the elegance of toss juggling with the,
uh,
physical efficiency of bounced juggling where he bounced the ball is off the
ground.
So if gravity is helping you juggle upside down and you're theoretically,
it'd be much more it didn't work out because if you can say in the book,
Yeah.
How else?
Anything,
anyone do anything upside down?
See does that,
he makes the ultimate machine,
which is one of our favorites,
which is a box and we've seen a copy of it.
A lot of people know this.
It's the box.
You press a button on the box,
a hand comes out of the box,
press the button,
turns itself off,
and then tracked back into the box.
You can see youtube videos of this,
by the way,
it's a physicists or a famous,
uh,
device and the ultimate machine.
Yeah.
The ultimate machine.
Its only purpose is to turn itself off.
So it's a,
so this is what Shannon does,
um,
for fun.
Oh,
there's the,
uh,
the uh,
Roman numeral calculator,
which is called throwback,
which is an acronym for I think thrifty,
a backwards looking Roman numeral calc or something like that.
But it's,
it's an all caps throwback is his name.
And,
um,
one of the first wearables,
which is,
uh,
a project you worked on with Ed Thorp to,
um,
beat the house at Roulette.
So the idea is that,
uh,
it,
um,
divides the roulette table up into eighths.
They got it into,
and if you can calculate a,
with some knowledge,
we,
if,
you know,
when the ball goes down and you start the computer,
uh,
it can signal which eighth of the roulette wheel,
the balls likely land in.
So Thorpe and him Wynn's money from the casinos in Vegas using this.
I'll,
the other cool thing is that its output is via kind of primitive ear bud.
So based on the frequency,
I think they had to memorize these frequencies.
You can tell based on frequency where the ball's going to land a onetime Thorpe,
the earbud falls out in someone screams because they think it's an insect
because no one really had seen ear buds.
I'm so authority gets in trouble a lot.
He had to run to the bathroom and put it back in.
So they,
uh,
they call this off because they were afraid of getting roughed up by the mafia,
which was,
uh,
which,
you know,
control because he doesn't Vegas at the time.
So they don't really take it as far as say,
you know,
the Mit blackjack team.
Um,
but they,
uh,
they,
maybe they could've been with,
this is just,
this is what the Shannon does with the sort of freedom that he gets to be a,
uh,
to be at a tinkerer,
prankster,
a jokester.
Oh.
And he also builds an earlier Chetland computer are called end game that can
handle a six pieces.
Um,
so,
you know,
he's all over the place in terms of his,
our hobbies,
um,
projects.
We can go on and on with this list.
But that's what it sort of makes them such a fun character.
And we think it's obviously you can,
you speculate a bit of when you write a biography,
but you think that that there's this playful spirit that even when he's not
unicycling down the hallway at bell labs,
it's in his work too because he was the kind of guy that just ask the silly
questions and got so much out of them.
Uh,
and it was sort of that courage to ask the ridiculous questions that enabled him
to do what he did.
It,
it's worth also,
right just
emphasizing at least using one example with the roulette,
a wearable device.
So the,
the origin story of this is Ed Thorp is at Mit and he tries to get an audience
with Claude Shannon.
He does.
And the Secretary Warren's in like collage hand and doesn't really have a lot of
patients.
So just you know,
keep your,
keep your stuff brief and he goes in and he's asking him about a blackjack paper
that he had written and Claude Shannon advised him that he wants to get it
published.
He needs to just change the name slightly and then [inaudible].
So what else are you working on and at dark sort of intimate said he's got this
idea for a roulette roulette wearable device that could give you a slight
advantage against the house and Roulette.
They spend the next eight months working to make this a reality.
They buy clutch in and buys a regulation,
let table from some warehouse or something.
They install it at the house and Ed Thorp for a period of time moves in and so
they just work on this thing.
These are two MIT professors like they,
yeah,
and Claude Shannon's like a duck giant was in the field by this point.
There's been eight months playing with the roulette ball and trying to figure
out sort of what the mechanics then as if that weren't enough,
they take the device to Las Vegas to to actually test it.
I think that one of the things that I am most inspired by about Claude Shannon
is just how far he took these curiosities.
I mean,
how many of us have an idea and it sort of goes into the trash.
It's like,
that's neat.
Okay,
I'm not going to devote eight months to try to do this.
But this student was a perfect stranger to Claude Shannon.
He didn't know him.
This is the first time they'd ever met.
And that leads to an eight month collaboration,
which just goes to show the sort of thing that happens when an idea entered
Claude Shannon's head,
sort of what could have emerged from it.
And we have physical representations of all of those things.
A lot of these devices are still stored at the MIT museum.
Uh,
they went on tour last year and to Germany and they were exhibited.
I think he's one of the only people that I've ever read of who has both papers
published in academic journals and things that have been in museums.
Uh,
this is a,
this is who he was.
It's a big part of the latter part of his life is this kind of tinkering.
And I think there's,
uh,
people like to say that the latter part of his life wasn't as productive or that
he didn't achieve what he did in 1948 and he kind of went downhill.
Um,
but,
but if you think about what you're comparing it to,
like the 1948 paper was extraordinary.
I mean,
it,
it has,
people have referred to it as sort of Einstein or Newton level thinking to say
that what he did after that didn't quite meet up match up,
I think is,
is a,
you're setting an extraordinarily high bar,
but B,
it misses all of these things that he did do.
The devices that he built,
he continued writing papers that took some of the theoretical work from 1948 and
showed engineers how they can practically apply it.
It's a period in which he's mentoring and working with some of the younger
generation of information theorists,
people like Robert Fannow and Bob Gallagher,
um,
who work with him on papers about pulse code modulation and other things.
And so there's this,
uh,
this period in the latter part of his life though,
which has a lot more freedom and flexibility and a lot of his most inventive
things come out of come out of that phase of his life and
wanted to add,
we did a Reddit Ama a couple of days ago and in the middle of it a guy emailed
me and said,
oh,
you have a picture in your book of Shannon's a juggling clown Diorama.
Uh,
he had a couple of these,
some of the juggling and life from that just look like it.
Uh,
I helped to build that.
I was a,
I think a high school student at the time and it was like saying it was such a
nice guy and it was,
it was one of the fun of summers of my life working with him and his workshop on
this.
And he sent us a picture of as proof of kind of like old Shannon in the,
I think this must've been the 70s,
early eighties.
And this a high school kid and you got the Ama.
It was awesome.
But it was just when he,
when he latched onto a project or someone who was interested in the same things,
uh,
you know,
he did it.
He made it.
He built an Rv.
I mean,
he,
like he,
so they bought an old school bus and like retrofitted it as an RV and there's
some accounts that suggests that it's like the world's first RV.
Um,
but,
but they just,
they,
those,
the Shannon's and Betty in particular,
and we should actually talk about her too,
because she's a huge part of this story.
His wife,
Betty is his equal in intellect in but also in tinkering.
So Theseus the mouse,
the video we watched the wiring for that was actually Betty.
Betty did the wiring.
That's a story we learn later.
Chan and gets the credit and deservedly so.
It was,
he was sort of thinking about it,
but Betty made sure the wire,
the wiring would work in that the thing would work as it needed to.
They were full partners in a lot of what they did.
We wrote a piece about this in scientific American that debuted a couple of days
ago.
And,
um,
have heard back from,
from people who knew Shannon to say,
you know,
thank goodness Benny finally kind of gets the credit that she deserves for a lot
of this.
She pushed him to try things like getting interested in the stock market,
which he becomes obsessed with for a brief period.
Um,
it,
the,
he had this,
this quality of being
able to,
uh,
ask this sort of absurd question,
but then try to build the answer to the absurd question.
Um,
and so there,
there were just robots.
He builds to perform functions that you sort of think to yourself,
like,
why,
why would you do?
Why,
why would you do that?
Um,
but the,
yeah,
so that,
that's just a little bit of a digression.
Not at all.
I was going to go into what about the women in this story,
but that could be a whole nother hour,
I think.
And I want to give the people here a chance to ask some questions.
So it's your turn.
Do you have some questions?
How would Claude Shannon described himself?
Um,
he wouldn't want to,
yeah,
that's a good one.
He was always,
yeah,
that,
that's a good point.
Is that in interviews,
uh,
he was just sort of an invasive,
a humble guy.
He didn't really,
he said,
well,
that just seemed like a pretty simple idea to me at the time.
Just came to me.
But I guess he would describe himself as someone who,
uh,
who liked puzzles,
who'd like to think about the way things worked.
Um,
and I think that kind of undersells who we was,
but I think you would have described himself in,
in pretty minimalist terms.
Uh,
there are a couple of interesting moments where Claude Shannon gets a little
more autobiographical.
Uh,
one thing that we've dug up from the archives was papers,
uh,
was a,
1950 to talk.
He gives on the topic of creative thinking to,
uh,
to bell labs,
engineers.
Oh,
in there,
there was one quote that we really like for him that we kind of mythical made it
the chapter title.
He said that,
um,
uh,
creative thinkers have this sort of,
um,
productive dissatisfaction.
They just,
they see when things don't fit right or don't work quite or puzzling and they
just stick with it to any follow through.
So I think he described himself as someone who was sort of usefully irritated in
a way sometimes.
Um,
he also,
uh,
much later on,
um,
uh,
when he wins the Kyoto prize,
which was sort of a set up as a a rivaled the Nobel prize in some fields the
Nobel didn't cover,
including a math which Claude Shannon gets a much later in his life.
He gives us sort of a hopeful view of his life,
talking about the,
of the progression of computers from a slide rules,
uh,
to the,
to the apple TV,
which he had many talks about.
Um,
uh,
how much he had gotten intellectualized pursuing his hobbies that he just
describes itself as a hobbyist and a lot of ways and how this was such an
integral part of his work.
So we gave a big a block quote of that speech in the,
uh,
in the book just because it hadn't been widely published and there aren't very
meantime to Shannon would open up about himself.
He was actually very nervous representing himself in public.
He gave the inaugural Claude Shannon and lecture,
um,
I think it was in Tel Aviv at the Technion.
Escalona Ashkelon.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
uh,
if someone said I had never used a nervous wreck,
it was named after him and,
uh,
he was being honored and you know,
he,
I think he was at the bar like pounding a couple of old fashion before he went
up there just because he did not like to represent himself in public.
So when he did,
it was worth,
it was worth pulling out.
That's a bit of a long winded answer,
but,
uh,
there,
there's another piece to that too,
which is,
um,
in the creative thinking lecture that he gives,
uh,
one of the things that nearly every person who we spoke to you about him when we
spoke to a lot of people who knew him,
he was incredibly
modest.
Um,
all in a way,
almost modest to a fault.
He did not go out and seek adulation.
Envelopes would come with awards or within invitations to speak at procedures,
lectures.
He would put them,
many of them and have been called letters I've procrastinated on sending back
for too long.
Um,
Eh,
awards,
honors recognitions.
It just,
it had no effect on him.
Uh,
there was even a reluctance in him.
I remember hearing from Peggy about the,
they found out that their dad had won the National Medal of science and that it
was sort of a,
it was a lift to get them to like kind of go to DC,
do the whole thing.
It was a famous photo of him and shaking Lyndon Johnson's hand.
Um,
there,
there are times when he wins awards and he just stashes them away when an
interviewer is asking about an award.
I think this was from an unpublished interview we uncovered.
Um,
he says,
well,
I have a couple of dozen of these things in the other room,
but,
but let's get back to the matter at hand,
which is sort of problem solving and understanding how things work.
You had this great line that we love that's uh,
if I can solve,
if I can find a solution to a mathematical theory,
I get a big bang out of it.
Um,
and he says it with like an exclamation point.
Uh,
and I think that the sort of self effacing modest quality of Shannon is
connected to this sort of not being affected by awards and honors.
And what that allows him to do is be free to explore whatever he wants.
Um,
he never feels a trace of self consciousness being the guy who founded
mathematical,
mathematical theory of communication and the guy who juggles in unicycles and
plays with children's toys,
uh,
this is just not,
it's not something that affects him.
Meanwhile,
many of his colleagues do wonder.
They're like,
this is a,
he,
you know,
he's too,
he's a named chair at Mit.
He's supposed to,
he's supposed to act a certain way.
Um,
we,
we find some inspiration in the fact that he didn't act that way,
that he just pursued what interested in interested him most.
So in a way,
if he had asked if he was going to be asset to describe himself,
I think it would if he was forced to do it and if he'd be forced,
he would say he was a problem solver.
That he enjoyed solving problems and figuring things out.
Uh,
but what he happened to figure out or things and things and problems that affect
us still.
You mentioned earlier that I was going to ask about,
uh,
these are people that influence Shannon,
but Shannon influenced to other people.
We know club Levy Strauss was a neighbor and then the series had effect on him.
I know that Leonard Meyer,
the philosopher I'm music considers the implications of the information theory
on here at music.
But you also mentioned that you didn't put in the book because there's a story
about an encounter with Steve jobs and seeing that the opera just premiered this
weekend in Santa Fe might be timely to hear about Shannon and jobs before we
have to cure.
Sure.
Um,
so this is a,
it's a,
it's a great story.
Uh,
this is the 1980s,
both jobs and Shannon are being given honorary degrees at the University of
Pennsylvania.
Um,
and again,
we sort of think about this like for Shannon,
he had so many honorary degrees did he actually rigged up a rotating tie rack,
which you put all the hoods on just to,
this is like how he thought,
how insignificant he thought these things were for the referral.
The rest of us by winter honorary degree,
I mean,
I want people to see that moment.
I walked through the front door,
I'm wearing the thing like,
yeah,
I want to wear the hood permanently for Santa.
And she's like,
Hey,
oh,
another honorary degree.
Here we go.
So they go to the University of Pennsylvania.
And,
uh,
at this point,
jobs is well known because of apple,
but not quite the sort of canonical figure,
iconic figure he is now.
And so after the ceremony is over,
everybody's sort of milling about the quad.
And Shannon has a group of people that random because Shannon is doctor Claude
Shannon and the people in this,
in that space know who he is.
He's got this throng of people around him and Steve Jobs really doesn't he?
He knows who Dr. Shannon is.
So he tries to elbow his way into an audience with and Janet and he does and he
gets up to him.
And the story according to Shannon's daughter is roughly that,
um,
Steve Jobs says,
uh,
talked to Shannon is such an honor to meet you.
Uh,
my name is Steve Jobs.
I work at Apple and Claude Shannon says,
well,
Steve,
it's great to meet you.
What do you do at Apple?
Uh,
uh,
and I,
and,
and the,
the end of the encounter,
uh,
as best as we can tell,
is that Steve Jobs actually sends the Shannon's and apple two e that he himself
assembled.
Uh,
and so they had this in there.
It had a pride of place in their,
in their home.
Um,
but it was a,
all of that,
the sort of recognition and fame and a sort of celebrity,
oh,
it was not really lost on Jen and it wasn't when he was after.
In fact,
in a way some of the commercialization of things we've sort of lost on Shannon
too.
It never struck him that he ought to like build a company and take it public.
Uh,
he was always just interested in sort of pursuing his own private curiosities.
But we did love investing in other people,
public company.
He did.
And he got,
he was wealthy by the end of his life.
Got on the ground floor of a number of,
of early companies,
including one that was acquired by Hewlett Packard.
Um,
I believe actually new Hewlett and Packard,
if I remember correctly.
But in any case,
that's the sort of famous Steve jobs and Dr. Shannon moment,
which is that at that moment in history,
Steve jobs had to explain to clutch and who he was,
uh,
which is pretty cool.
Well,
thank you so much for coming and thank you for writing the book.
Thank you so much.